une bd à bien utiliser la nouvelle
application techtoc durant la campagne
électorale
cette application connaît un grand
succès chez les plus jeunes il faut le
dire déjà un milliard et demi de
téléchargement nelly brière est
spécialisée en stratégie de
communication numérique et médias
sociaux nelly brière bonsoir bonsoir
est ce que tu es content qu en fait
tic-tac qui est une version chinoise
parce que ça appartient à une entreprise
chinoise qui s'appelle douillet une
douane shipping qui veut dire petite
vidéo vibrato parce que c'est ce que
c'est son application mobile qui permet
de produire des petites vidéos de 15
secondes à partir d'extraits sonores
soit de musique populaire et pop
électronique etc ou d'extraits sonores
qui proviennent de films et là on a
toute une panoplie d'outils pour faire
des effets visuels incroyables des
filtres de la réalité augmentée il y en
a vraiment beaucoup
il y en a et ça se renouvelle
régulièrement et laon rivalisent de
créativité à travers toute une série de
hashtag qui sont des fois des chalets
qui sont des fois des propositions de
mime
en fait c'est à dire qu'on peut utiliser
un concept il le reprendre
créativement de toutes sortes de
manières au marché les jeunes très fort
ça marche chez les jeunes très fort et
ça génère plein de phénomènes culturels
sa vie d'ailleurs le fameux ok boom 1 ça
vient d'autres secteurs
oui c'est un duo c'était une réponse à
un baby boomer qui faisait un peu la
morale ou milena rios là dessus et là ce
hashtag leur a été propulsé carrément
sur la plateforme l été dernier et c'est
très différent des autres types de
réseaux sociaux qu'on connaît les bons
vieux twitter facebook instagram
snapshot on peut retrouver des éléments
par exemple sur instagram ou est-ce que
de la réalité augmentée
mais c'est une plateforme qui est
spécialisée dans une fonctionnalité en
fait parce qu'on veut sur facebook par
exemple il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
fonctionnalités là dessus c'est très
complexe comme plateforme saas est une
application mobile qui est vraiment
spécialisé dans la production de mini
sketchs ça ressemble un peu à quand on
était jeunes par exemple on pouvait
prendre des vieilles cassettes vhs que
ce film est la thur des cassettes audio
ou imiter ddd faire du lipsync et ses
ballons peut le faire mais à être vu
dans le monde anticipe et récolté une
popularité incroyable avec des like et
récolter de l'argent
pas vraiment pas politique toker en fait
c'est sûr qu'à l'entreprise
non parce que ce qu'ils peuvent cumuler
c'est une grande popularité après soit
peut-être avec des partenariats
ils peuvent j'ai avoir de l'argent mais
c'est pas comme youtube ou est ce qu'il
ya une partie qui est rétribué aux
producteurs de contenus et même si de
l'argent à la clé parce que les gens qui
utilisent top pour acheter des cadeaux
descoings en fait de l'argent virtuel
acheter des cadeaux qu'ils vont donner à
ceux qui font de diffusion directe c'est
seulement le petit cadeau virtuel qu'on
n'y a pas d'argent à la clé l'argent
votre totalement dans l'entreprise et
l'entreprise le fait commun que comment
elle fit son argent ben justement en
vendant ces petits cadeaux là mais sinon
il ya de la publicité évidemment
d'ailleurs il semblerait que en chine
ils réussissent à capter 23 % des
revenus issus des médias numériques ce
qui est quand même pas mal
est-ce que c'est sécuritaire est-ce que
c'est sécuritaire ça n'est pas pour qui
de la part des études unis en ce moment
il ya des controverses parce que étant
l'ex d'entreprises chinoises byden ce
qui est derrière ce secteur et que une
amende qui était donné par ce qu on
récoltait des données sur des enfants de
moins de 13 ans 5.7 miller d'un million
de dollars en février dernier ce qui est
quand même une amende record
alors on se demande qu'est ce qu'il fait
avec ces données là on a peur que ce
soit une forme d'espionnage on sait que
beaucoup de surveillance électronique en
chine
alors on se demandait ce qu'on fait du
profilage commercial alexiou je ne sais
trop
c'est des données souvent sur des
enfants alors de ce côté là il ya une
controverse mais d'un autre côté c'est
de la production de chorégraphies de
danse c'est quand même très naïf comme
contenu évidemment il peut y avoir des
connotations sexuelles parce qu'on y
mette ses vedettes préférées dans les
pop dans la musique pop puis on s'est
parfois ça peut être un peu très sexuel
comme ce qui prime
prenez là dedans et des fois comme c'est
déjà en forme et peut y avoir de la
captation de vidéos de photos qui sont
utilisés après dans les réseaux plus
sombres de pédophiles qui font des dix
fake avec ça ah la la
est-ce que c'est l'avenir des réseaux
sociaux ce type d'application et cette
application là je pense que certaines
fonctions de cette application le
constituent oui l'avenir
c'est à dire justement de faire la
production avec la réalité augmentée
c'est magnifique parce que les enfants
apprennent à faire de la réalisation du
montage
après une plainte chose qui va
probablement utile dans différents
secteurs de dans le milieu du travail
même plus tard mais ça va être avoir
tout change très vite dans le numérique
là j'aurais pas pu vous il ya cinq ans
le secteur qui allait arriver sur le
bois la fac ci ça va trouver pour dire
pas de politique
donc ça c'est l'autre aspect qui
reprochaient stoxx est cueilli une
censure totale de tout ce qui est
politique là dessus on voit pas rien de
moncton mais % en dix ans la plateforme
faut mentionner oui mais tout ce qui est
politique c'est pas juste qu est-ce qui
en compte ce n'est pas juste une censure
chinoise
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir
qu'on reproche l'ascenseur qui est fait
au niveau des contenus politiques à tik
tok aux états unis en même temps qu'on
reproche à facebook de ne pas censurer
les contenus de nature politique de gars
comme une schizophrénie la danse qui
demande et parce que je pense que c'est
un sujet complexe qui est pas totalement
compris la de la classe politique c'est
l'une des applications les plus
téléchargées dans le monde
oui en ce moment en fait elle est dans
celles qui sont le plus dali plus
téléchargées il ya quand même encore
whatsapp messenger qui serait en avance
là mais sont pas très loin il faut
qu'elle fait partie des plus
téléchargées et son avantage c'est
qu'elle n'est pas en amérique du nord
elle est tous et en chine et en asie et
près de 150 marchés je suis ce que je
veux faire ce soir
non c'est pas vrai nelly brière merci
beaucoup merci bien